[Music]
when was the last time you could walk
into a room and say that
this design just came to me in a dream
and it's intuition we all have super
powers the great aim of education is not
knowledge but action and this is where
the design singapore council scholarship
comes in the group the next generation
of design leaders to transform work and
business to raise the quality of life
connect communities and even push the
boundaries of the design industry to
give the young generation the permission
to
explore and also to understand what goes
on the ground in design you know you
kind of need a lot of collaboration
between views between disciplines on
statewide we've learned into action 95
of all of us all of us you know on earth
don't really have a chance to discover
what their superpowers are all about we
leave those superpowers dormant to be a
great designer is not just about getting
all your software skills it's also about
you know having the attitude the mindset
of curiosity and empathy the war on
imagination is very often aware that
we're raging inside of our self design
is really about fighting the impossible
with solutions made of beauty and
meaning and that's definitely where
creative juices will flow and sparkle of
life don't forget to work on yourself we
all have superpowers
[Music]